مشهد ماساوي ظل لقصر عدلي بيروت عكس الدرك
الذي وصلت اليه ازمه لبنان على مختلف
السعودي والتي طاولت العدل واسيسه
ما جرى امام هذا الصرح
قضائي بين المحقق العدلي في قضيه انفجار
المرفق طارق البيطار ومدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات على خلفيه اطلاق الاخير صراحه
جميع الموقوفين
على الملف العدلي اللي هو ملك بالنهايه
صادره عن المحقق العدل اليوم ما انه
موقوفين باشاره من النيابه العامه لا يصير
تاركم بالطريقه كيان المفترات يتم اخلاء
سبيلهم عن طريق النيابه عن طريق العدل
ويتيار اليوم تم الاستلام على صلاحيه رغم
انه قرارات القادم هي قرارات نافذه غير
مقابل الاستعمال
[تصفيق]
لقصر العدل باهالي ضحايا انفجار وتحول
المشهد الى هرج ومرج وتدافع بعد تعرض عدد
من نواب البرلمان الذين حضروا تضمنا
للمضايقات والتهجم من قبل مرافقه وزير
العدل
بلد ما بيقوم ما ممكن يظبط اصل ما في فاصل
السلطات واذا ما بيوقف التدخل السياسي
بالقضاء هذا اللي حاولنا ان النيله اليوم
حولنا نقول له لوزير العدل هو وزير وصايه
وعنده صلاحيات لما بشوف يخروءات كثير
كبيره بالقضاء يقدر يتصرف طبعا
الميليشيا اللي بتحمي وزير العدل
اتصرفت مع انه بطريقه اقل ما يقال فيها
انه وحشيه ما اطلع بالرئيس انه نعرف شو
صار المطلب الرئيس انه هالناس اللي كانوا
قاعدين بشغلهم من بيتهم قتلهم ببيوتهم
بدام بارد وهلا عم يقضوا على عياله وعلى
اهلهم وعلى القضيه ويزيحوا همم القاضي
بيطار على جنب نحن
موجودين
اقتحام من نفذها المعتصمون باتجاه قصر
العدل لم ينعقد مجلس القضاء الاعلى بحجه
رفض ضغط الشارع وتدخل النواب سقوط مدون
سجل لدور القضائي في لبنان بما يعنيه من
ارساء العدل والعداله وهيبتهما او بما
يمثله من عمود اساسيين من اعمده حول ما
يطفي صوره قاتمه على مال الامور في القادم
من الايام رينادويه العربيه بيروت